الله اكبر طوفان الاقصى لا يزال يشعل
مستوطنات غلاف غزه لليوم الثاني على
التوالي هناك تدوي دون توقف صافرات
الانذار ومن حين لاخر تظهر صور جديده
لتكشف كم كان طوفان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
عاتيا داخل المستوطنات
الاسرائيليه تركزت الاشتباكات في مستوطنات
وبلدات الغلاف شرق خان يونس اكثر
المواجهات شراسه بين الم قاومه وقوت
الاحتلال كانت في كيبوتس ماجن اذ لجا
الجيش الاسرائيلي لسلاح المدفعيه
والدبابات للرد على هجوم مقاتلي القسام
وفصائل المقاومه وفي كيبوت سليم في النقب
تحدث الجيش الاسرائيلي عن تصديه لعمليه
تسلل لمقاومين كتائب القسام قالت انها
نفذت عمليات تسلل جديده لتعزيز مقاتليها
في بؤر الاشتباكات بالمقاتلين والعتاد
وذلك في صوفا وحولي وييد ولليوم الثاني لا
تزال الاشتباكات تدور في كل من زكيم وكفار
عزه وبيري ورعي وكسو فيم وفي سديروت تجددت
الاشتباكات بين مقاومين فلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال في محيط مقر شرطه سديروت حيث
يشتبه الجيش بوجود خلايا للمقاومه مستتره
داخل البلده وقد بدات السلطات الاسرائيليه
اخلاء جميع البلدات والمستوطنات والكيبوتس
الواقعه على بعد 4 كيلومترات من الحدود مع
غزه
فعلى مراحله سيتم اخلاء مستوطنات نحل عوز
ايرز برعام مفلاسيم كفار عوز جم اور هانير
ايفيم ناتيف هعس ياد موردخاي كارميه زكيم
كيرم شالوم كيسوفيم حوليت صوفا نيريم نير
عوز العين الثالثه نيريت حاك بيري ماجين
رعيم سعاد
عليم اما الحدود بين لبنان واسرائيل فقد
شهدت توترا وان كان اقل حده بكثير لكن انه
مبعث قلق لمؤسسات صنع القرار في تل ابيب
التي تتخوف من اشتعال جبهات اخرى حيث اعلن
حزب الله اللبناني استهدافه ثلاثه مواقع
للاحتلال الاسرائيلي في مزارع شبعه وقصفه
مواقع الرادار وزبد ورويس العلم بقذائف
مدفعيه وصواريخ موجهه رد الجيش الاسرائيلي
بقصف مدفعي على مزرعه بسره اللبنانيه
المتاخمه لمزارع شبعه وبعد ساعات اعلن
الجيش الاس اسرائيلي اطلاق صاروخ من
منظومه الدفاع الجوي باتريوت لاعتراض
طائره مسيره فوق صفد لكن مالبثت تل ابيب
انفت تعرض اجوائها لاي اختراق من جهه
لبنان يحدث ذلك وسط تحليق مكثف لطائرات
استطلاع اسرائيليه تمسح القطاع الشرقيه من
جنوب لبنان لم تتحسب اسرائيل ان يكون
مواطنوها هدفا لهجمات بعيدا عن جبهات
المواجهه المالوفه حدث ذلك في مدينه
الاسكندريه اذ يهاجم شرطي مصري بسلاحه
الشخصي سياحا اسرائيليين في مزار عمود
الصواري ويقتل اثنين منهم منذ عام
1979 ترتبط القاهره وتل ابيب بمعاهده سلام
لكن على المستوى الشعبي ثمت رفض واسع
للتطبيع يترجم المصريون رفضهم هذا بعمليات
ضد الاسرائيليين من ذلك تنظيم ثوره مصر
بدايه ثمانينيات القرن الماضي الذي نفذ
هجمات ضد الوفود الاسرائيليه واع ضاء
السلك الدبلوماسي الاسرائيلي في قلب
القاهره اما مسلسل العمليات الفرديه فبدا
الجندي سليمان خاطر عام
1985 حين قتل اسرائيليين حاولوا تخطي
الحدود جنوب سيناء بعد خمسه اعوام عاد
الجندي المصري ايمن حسن ليكرر السيناريو
ذاته بعمليه عرفت براس النقب قتل خلالها
عده اسرائيليين على الحدود بين مصر
واسرائيل وفي يونيو الماضي تسلل الجندي
المصري محمد صلاح من نقطه مراقبه في شبه
جزيره سيناء الى داخل اسرائيل وقتل جنودا
اسرائيليين في تبادل لاطلاق النار قبل ان
يقتل لكن هجوم الاسكندريه يحمل رمزيه
وخصوصيه بانه اول عمليه تنفذ بعيدا عن
الحدود مع اسرائيل وفي قلب مدينه باهميه
الاسكندريه